i have this theory that the the new like
animation that plays when you hit like
on a youtube video on mobile is just
there to increase engagement it's the
exact same thing as when you like a post
with the hashtag wwdc now apple has to
pay for the hashtag
but same idea anyway yo what's up mkbhd
here so apple's wwdc was today it's
their developer conference so we know
there's going to be a ton of software
announcements and there was but of
course we were expecting a little bit of
an extra surprise on top maybe some
hardware and we got that too so there's
a lot to talk about today
let's just jump right into it philip
defranco so the biggest update is what's
coming to ios 16. this will be coming
out eventually as an update to your
iphone and launching on the next iphone
when that comes out in the fall and
there's a lot of new features here so
the biggest one easily is the new
overhaul to the lock screen on our
phones so forever just for the longest
time our lock screens on our iphones
have been the same thing it's the time
at the top and then just a long list of
notifications and then whatever your
wallpaper was behind all that
fine in ios 16 the lock screen is way
more i think the word is personalized
which is actually not typical of what we
see from apple but this is a really nice
update here so you can mess with not
just the fonts and colors of your clock
which is cool but it'll even play with
your wallpaper a little bit so if you
have a portrait mode photo or something
with depth in your wallpaper that can
look really cool
but most importantly two things one
notifications now will roll in from the
bottom of the display it's the opposite
of android right now and that's much
better for actually seeing your
wallpaper and it's much more reachable
if say apple is getting ready to sell a
bunch of really big iphones but then
also two
widgets on the lock screen that that is
some real personality on a lock screen
it's a welcome feature of course not
only that we also be able to save
multiple different lock screens with
different wallpapers different clocks
and different combinations of widgets
and save those lock screens so they can
switch between those at any time it's
like swapping watch faces on your watch
but then you can also tie a lock screen
to a focus mode so if you have your
sleep focus mode and you have your sleep
home screen you now also have a sleep
lock screen with your sleep widgets and
your sleep clock and you can have your
work lock screen and your do not disturb
lock screen all those things will be
synced when you change your focus mode
they'll all have different wallpapers
different clocks different widgets
whatever you want that is personality
that that is really nice music controls
are also at the bottom now too instead
of being this massive huge thing right
under your clock in the middle oh and
there's now live updating notifications
too so you know some apps will send you
just a bunch of notifications as things
update or as things change uh maybe a
live score update for example sends you
one after the first quarter and at half
time well now there's a new feature
called what is it called uh live
activities but it's exactly what it
sounds like now one notification can
continually update with the latest
information instead of having a bunch of
notifications from that one app
that is nice and i know a bunch of apps
that could use that update so the lock
screen is a big new thing in ios 16. but
then there's also a bunch of little
features sprinkled within the rest of
the os2 one of them in messages is you
can now edit
imessage messages so that is going to be
hilarious uh i kind of want to try to
see if there's any sort of indicator
next to the message that's been edited
i'll play around with this in the beta i
would say definitely get subscribed to
see the videos on these new softwares
when i actually get to play with them
and dive into them deep and make my
feature reviews but yes you will be able
to edit imessages and you'll also be
able to undo send and you can also mark
a thread as unread and yes i am a little
bit salty that you can edit an imessage
before you can edit tweets
assuming that doesn't happen by fall
there's also a couple new share play
experiences to easily discover things
you can watch together with someone and
they dramatically improved on-device
dictation so you can move back and forth
between voice and touch as you're typing
something this feature looks really cool
it actually looks very similar to what
google just did with the last version of
the pixel which made the pixel the best
voice to text phone on the planet and
really change the way i use it so i'm
looking forward to seeing if this is as
good as that
but that's a welcome feature but then
there's a couple other highlights do you
remember uh live text where you take a
picture of a sign or any anything with
text in it and you can always just
highlight the text in that photo
straight away well they're bringing that
to videos so any video you take with
text in it you'll be able to pause and
live select and if that works well
that's going to be i think incredible i
mean i feel like that's low-key unreal
for students like you just record your
whiteboard after a lecture and it just
makes your notes more useful but then
they took it another step further and
they also showed a demo of touching and
holding a subject of a photo and it
lifts the subject
into an object that you can copy and
paste
like text that that is
that's
amazing obviously it's pretty next level
it kind of just takes all the work out
of like tracing something out and making
it like a discord sticker or something
we would have used in the past so that
again i want to try it but that seems
amazing then apple maps adds multi-stop
routing apple news adds more live sports
coverage they also overhauled the home
app in a way that i would very much like
google to copy with their home app with
the organization and filter toggles at
the top and live camera views this is a
really nice upgrade but then that's
pretty much it for ios again it's not
you know some huge visual overhaul
that's not what's happening with ios
updates anymore even though it did
happen with android but lots of you know
neat features stacked on top of each
other boom ios update
can we talk about carplay for a second
so they had this statement on stage that
apparently 79 of new car buyers
would only consider a new car if it has
carplay in it which i don't even know if
that's accurate that seems a little high
but i think the point that they're
trying to make that i agree with is that
most in-car infotainment systems suck
they've been bad for a long time and so
just having apple carplay in your car
made the infotainment system much better
and much more usable that's what people
wanted and that was the old car play
today we got a sneak peek at the next
generation of carplay coming out later
this year which not only revamps the ui
a bit but basically is now able to just
take over a new car's entire software
experience on every screen lots of new
cars have screens instead of tacks so
the screen behind the steering wheel a
screen to the side of the steering wheel
and carplay will literally just be able
to take them all over and be consistent
across everything so this this is pretty
sick i've always used carplay when i
have the opportunity on a car that has
it two things come to mind one
why
would anyone ever use the built-in
infotainment system in a car if you have
carplay just doing everything and it
seems like there's no motivation now for
car manufacturers to get really good at
making that software it's just not gonna
be as good as car play i don't know
maybe that's a pessimistic view but two
hey apple have you ever considered
making the rest of the car and this is
probably a totally new idea you've never
heard before but you know you've made a
bunch of the pieces of the software and
using the car maybe the rest maybe like
an electric
it's probably never mind so okay when
watch os came up on the screen at the
keynote as the next software they were
going to talk about the first thing i
thought was
group challenges please let us do group
fitness challenges if they don't do it
now are they ever going to let us do it
please add that feature so they added
some other more granular information for
tracking certain activities so now
instead of just doing a running workout
with just distance and elevation like
they always do this will keep track of
not just heart rate but heart rate zones
and let you set up interval training if
you want to do that type of stuff which
i do that's super useful to me uh
triathlon workouts will now
automatically be able to detect when
you've switched from swimming to biking
and to running so you don't have to do
it for you for yourself
cool but there's also some more
information that will be tracked with
sleep so it'll track your sleep stages
so i do wear the watch to sleep and it
does give me a very basic overview of
what's happening but now it'll tell you
all the same stuff basically samsung's
apps has been telling me which is if
you're in rem sleep or core sleep or
light sleep or deep sleep cool but yeah
no group challenges it never came up
they talked about fitness all the time
and you can actually close your rings
with just an iphone now and no watch so
they do want people closing their rings
and feeling motivated by the rings but
yeah no
no group challenges there's got to be a
reason they haven't added it yet right
but then we got to our first bit of
hardware at wwdc which is the second
generation of apple silicon in the mac
the m2 chip it is officially unveiled
and we'll get to hear all about it now
we knew the apple silicon transition
because they told us would take about
two years right so the only computer
that hasn't
transitioned from intel stuff to apple
silicon is the mac pro that'll probably
happen sometime in the next few months
we didn't get a teaser of it or anything
but that's the last one but this m2 is
basically just a second generation of
the baseline bottom end of the episode
lineup so m1 pro and m1 ultra are still
higher end chips than this but m2 is
replacing m1 and it's interesting this
is the first time they're going to be
able to compare a new mac chip to
themselves to something that they've
done in the past so it'll be interesting
to see what type of performance gains to
expect and there's some decent numbers
so it's a new generation still five
nanometer chip with 20 billion
transistors which is 25 more than m1 the
unified memory bandwidth is now 100
gigabytes per second which is 50 more
than m1 it supports up to 24 gigs of
unified memory which again is 50 more
than m1 and cpu performance is generally
about 20 percent higher while gpu
performance is about 35 percent higher
and the media engine gets a huge upgrade
as well so while this is the lowest end
chip in the lineup this is absolutely
going to get some claimed performance
improvements over the m1
i could do a whole separate video on the
graphs and the performance stuff i might
actually do that uh obviously that's
down the road but you do need a new
machine to put these new chips in and so
we got that too actually we literally
got two but the one that most people are
gonna care about is the new macbook air
it's a new redesign it comes in four
colors now and it's got a brand new
refreshed look it's not a wedge shape
anymore it's absolutely more flat and
it's looking much more similar in
aesthetics to the other new macbook pros
it's still extremely thin 11.3
millimeters thick and 2.7 pounds and
overall 20 percent less internal volume
than the last macbook air
but it gets a new magsafe port for
charging on the left along with two
thunderbolt ports and on the right
there's a high impedance audio jack the
keyboard now has a full size function
row at the top with a touch id button
along with a new quad speaker setup and
new microphones but the biggest change
is actually the display it's a larger
13.6 inch screen in almost the same
footprint as the last macbook air it
gets brighter now up to 500 nits
matching the m1 macbook pro but you can
see it has a new notch the aesthetic
apple is slowly getting us used to with
their new laptop form factor which
includes a new 1080p webcam this is a
large and overall i think quite nice set
of updates for the world's most popular
laptop the new chip and all the new
designs and things surrounding it but
definitely get subscribed i'm going to
be making a full entire video on my more
dedicated detailed thoughts on breaking
down this new laptop and all the changes
and what i think people will like about
it and what i like about it including
why i think the new midnight color
might not actually be the best color to
pick
but overall really good laptop
maybe a little bit on the other end of
the spectrum is the new m2 macbook pro
also unveiled and i say that because
that is basically the same exact machine
as the m1 macbook pro
but just with an m2 chip inside it now
that's it same exact thing and that's
not a bad thing that's obviously already
a very good laptop that i liked a lot
but it just feel like it didn't get the
same amount of love as the other new
macbook pro so that was interesting to
see so the new m2 macbook air starts at
11.99 so the price does go up but they
are keeping the m1 macbook air around
which is a couple years old but they're
keeping it at that 9.99 price so you can
still get in to a macbook air at 9.99
and then the new m2 macbook pro is 12.99
i'll get more into this in the other
video but i feel like there's not a
whole lot of people that i would
recommend the m2 macbook pro to
you're giving up magsafe you're giving
up the new display you're giving up the
new speakers the new webcam the new
fast charging all to just have slightly
better sustained performance which
you know you probably should end up
getting a 14-inch m1 pro at that point
but again i'll get more into that in the
other video but of course we were all
wondering what the name of the software
would be that they would run on these
new macs they do this whole big reveal
for the software name every year and so
the new version of mac os for 2022 mac
os ventura so they walked us through it
ventura again is not so much an
aesthetic change as much as it's a bunch
of useful features put together in one
place you know a couple of the stock
apps get better the mail app has better
search features finally uh facetime
handoff between devices is super dope
you know get home you're on a facetime
on your phone you want to switch to the
computer
one button shows up and it's a click
away that's awesome but probably the
most interesting feature that i'm
definitely going to want to try is
called continuity camera
and as you can probably understand by
the name that is literally just using
the cameras on the back of the iphone
as your webcam so there's this optional
belkin made magsafe mount coming out
later at some point this year and i'm
sure tons of other companies are working
on some version of this also but
basically when it's enabled and your
phone is stable your mac will just see
all the cameras on the back of your
iphone as webcam options basically
admitting that yeah webcams usually suck
so here's an actually good camera but
the craziest part this is actually
probably the one feature that actually
really surprised me and blew me away on
stage so it's facing you it's the webcam
right it's got the ultra white here as
well
it will see that ultra wide camera and
because it's so wide and it's facing
down in front of you it can actually
take the edge of that frame to see
what's in front of you
cut it out flip it over stretch it and
do some processing to give you a
straight up top top-down view of what's
on your desk it's called desk view and
damn that is cool i want to try to see
exactly how it's creating that angle
like i really want to try this and see
how close to the computer i can get with
the phone that will actually see the
keyboard and everything in front of me
but that is some impressive and clever
processing happening right there well
played apple well played the mac also
got this feature called stage manager
i found it kind of odd on the mac but i
think it'll make a little bit more sense
in a second basically it's this side
dock looking thing for your active
windows and it keeps the app or apps
that you're working on front and center
so on stage it's basically acting like
another set of window management tools
um i'm personally probably going to
stick with spaces the way i use that on
the mac already but this feature is also
coming to ipad os 16 so the ipad gets
this so there were a lot of rumors you
know people talking about the ipad is
finally going to get this overhaul to be
more of a computer you know wwdc that
would be the time to do it and this is
kind of along those lines so the m1
ipads will now let you extend your
display onto an external display instead
of mirroring and then stage manager acts
as a sort of window management system so
for the first time on an ipad you can
have
overlapping windows and move them around
like this and actually resize them and
you can also pair things up move them
off to the side and have a total of up
to eight active windows open four on the
ipad and four more on the external
display all in the foreground that is
definitely something to keep an eye on i
i like the way the ipad sort of
slowly evolves towards being a more
capable computer it is frustratingly
slow but i think that's something i'm
going to be giving a shot i'm going to
dive into the betas get to know the
features and actually tell you guys if
they're worth knowing about and using or
not but yeah that's about it for new
software stuff that's ipad os and that's
that's dub dub oh wait one more thing
sorry i almost forgot
the ipad finally gets a weather app
finally they did it they decided it was
good enough
yeah i don't know if i don't know if a
calculator is happening anytime soon but
bravo weather so get subscribed to see
the videos that i'm talking about that
are also upcoming also
check out the link below i did a master
class it's just been a long time coming
that actually am able to say that out
loud
so if you want to you can sign up that
window for signing up for it and
everyone taking the class at once is now
open super cool and you also get a link
a discount if you sign up at the link
below so that's also below that's all i
got to say for this video stay tuned
catch you guys the next one peace
[Music]